you're gonna fall right back into
somebody else
who's going to put their ring through
your nose and drag you around their life
unless you decide for the first time
since you were a little bitty girl
that what I want matters and what I need
matters
and the life that I have laid out in
front of me these dreams that I have
I get to see them to fulfillment
and of course having a partner in that
Adventure would be great but I'm worth
more than getting hit
I'm worth more than getting stolen from
because I guarantee you he took your
money worth more than being called
stupid ridiculous because I didn't get a
particular job and I know he Cut You
Down
like you're you're worth more than all
of that